débution nos sénateurs vont nous
rejoindre au fur et à mesure ça il
rentrent voilà c'est le café la bonne
honur du café bien mes chers collègues
nous allons donc poursuivre nos
auditions et donc nous recevons ce matin
jean-renis le serf donc Président et
Madame Virginie Magnant directrice de la
Caisse nationale de solidarité pour
l'autonomie la SNSA sur le proj de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2024 je vous rappelle également que
cette audition fait l'objet d'une
captation vidéo et retransm en direct
pardon plutôt sur le site du Sénat voilà
et donc je vais vous demander bien
entendu aux uns et aux autres de pouvoir
solliciter donc nos invités par vos
questionsblement nous entendrons les
rapporteurs sur le sujet et puis d'ors
et déjà je commence tout simplement pour
cher président avec le plaisir de vous
retrouver par vous donner la parole pour
un propos liminaire
voilà je suis pas venu depuis un moment
c'est
une maison que je connais bien que je
retrouve toujours avec effectivement un
très grand plaisir et c'est même la
première commission à laquelle j'ai
participer c'était celle-ci en des temps
très anciens c'était en
2001 avant de m'exider à la commission
des lois qui était intéressante aussi
très très bien très très heureux
effectivement d'être au Sénat pour cette
présentation par le président du conseil
de la CNSA que je suis et puis ensuite
par la directrice générale effectivement
de de de cette 5 une branche de la
sécurité sociale du PLFSS 2024 d'abord
pour rappeler des des choses qui sont
certainement des vérité d'évidence mais
il faut toujours à mon avis les rappeler
parce qu'elles sont utiles c'est que la
la 5è branche de la sécurité sociale la
CNSA est organisée d'une manière un peu
original c'est dire que il n'y a pas
d'autres exemples effectivement de de
de d'une situation effectivement où le
conseil de la CNSA qui n'est pas un
conseil exécutif qui est un conseil
instance de de de de conseil instance de
de critique instance de demande
d'innovation de recommandation où le
conseil est composé effectivement de
l'ensemble des parties prenantes de
l'autonomie pour reprendre l'expression
qui était celle de de de Madame Marianne
monchand qui m'a précédé effectivement à
la présidence de de du conseil de la
CNSA et dire que nous sommes on essaie
d'être complémentaire avec Virginie
Manan et avec effectivement l'ensemble
de ses collaborateurs mais on est dans
des situations différentes vous avez
d'un côté effectivement
la caisse la direction de la caisse le
personnel de la caisse B qui fait très
bien son métier
mais je retire le met qui est
effectivement par hypothèse loyale au
pouvoir public quel qu'il soit et dont
les capacités de critique sont quand
même beaucoup plus limitées que les
capacités de critique du Conseil le
Conseil ensemble des parties prenantes
ça veut dire effectivement qu'il y a
cert des représentants de l'État mais il
y a aussi et je le désire surtout des
représentants de toutes les grandes
fédérations de personnes ées et
fédération de personnes en situation de
handicap il y a les départements il y a
les institutions de l'autonomie il y a
les des des des trois personnalités
qualifiées euh j'ai appris que j'étais
qualifié comme ça ils ont été désignés
si vous voulez qui a son 3/ 52 he qui
représente donc peu de chose en nombre
et puis il y a aussi bien évidemment
comme là comme les dans les autres
caisses la représentation à la fois des
employeurs et des agents qui travaillent
dans le secteur de l'autonomie hein les
syndicats patronaux les
syndicats
de d'agents et on essae au niveau de la
caisse autant que faire ce peut d'avoir
une opinion au niveau du conseil de de
la CNSA d'avoir une opinion qui soit
soit unanime comme c'est pas toujours
toujours possible soit extrêmement
majoritaire mais souvent le les avis
sont unanimes par exemple récemment la
la la la CNSA a présenté un un avis sur
le Conseil a présenté un avis sur la fin
de vie ce ce cet avis a été voté à
l'unanimité par les membres du conseil
et ma voix importe peu si vous voulez si
ce n'était que ma voix ma voix elle
commence à importer lorsque
j'exprime la volonté effectivement d'un
conseil qui réunit l'ensemble des
parties prenantes euh je dis souvent que
le conseil c'est tout sauf la caution
des pouvoirs publics le conseil c'est
peut-être la conscience des pouvoirs
publics mais certainement pas la caution
nous nous ne ménageons absolument pas
les critiques je pense d'ailleurs je
l'ai dit à diverses reprises euh nous
sommes des enquikineurs pour pas
utiliser une formule qui a été utilisée
par d'autres récemment et si nous
n'étions pas des en kikineerss nous ne
ferions pas correctement notre travail
notre notre travail essentiel c'est
d'attirer l'attention sur ce qui ne va
pas c'est des trains qui qui n'arrivent
pas à l'heure qui qui nous intéressent
et puis mettre effectivement les
pouvoirs publics devant leur
responsabilité par rapport à ces
problèmes alors pouvoir public à qui
j'ai fait un petit reproche mais ils y
étaent pour rien tout à fait récemment
c'est de dire écoutez avec euh je suis
je suis président de la CNSA depuis du
conseil de la CNSA depuis moins de 2 ans
on n'a pas le temps de de de de de de de
de vous apprécier que vous êtes déjà
partis puisque en moins de 2 ans c'est
la trème équipe he que j'ai pour prendre
en charge les problèmes effectivement du
grand âge et les problème du handicap ce
qui au-delà de la sympathie que j'ai
pour les uns et pour les autres n'est
pas une excellente manière de pouvoir
gérer effectivement dans la continuité
les problèmes qui se posent alors les
les les obsessions si vous voulez du
conseil qui se retranscrivent dans
l'avis d'ailleurs qui qui a été qui a
été remis elles sont nombreuses et elles
tiennent fondamentalement à la volonté
d'avoir une cohérence d'ensemble sur les
problèmes du handicap une cohérence
d'ensemble sur les problèmes de la
fragilité que nous avons beaucoup de mal
à voir se mettre en place année après
année si je reprends la question de la
fin de vie le le le rapport de la fin de
vie par exemple euh c'était
l'opportunité de dire que un arbre aussi
important qu'il soit ne doit pas cacher
la forêt que la forêt c'était les
conditions de vie des personnes âgées et
des personnes en situation de handicap
et que bien évidemment c'était ces
conditions qui amenaient un certain
nombre effectivement de de de de nos
semblables à souhaité une aide active à
mourir donc on n pas à se prononcer he
sur l' qui va mourir nous nous conseil
de la CDS on n'est pas là pour pour
décider à la place des autres nous nous
ne proposons ni le maintien intégral des
lois cletti ni le suicide assisté ni
l'euutthanasie on dit simplement tout
cela relève de l'autorité du législateur
mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est quel est
le contexte et le contexte permettra
effectivement au législateurs de prendre
les meilleures
décisions et je un dernier point
là-dessus et puis je passe à autre chose
pour dire que avec les auditions que
nous avons fait nous sommes très
inquiets sur la possibilité d'extension
d'un texte législ ative d'interprétation
contre les gemes moi j'étais enseigné en
droit l'interprétation contre les gemes
je connais bien et nous avons vu par
exemple élu des des des des des
responsables des des Pays-Bas disons
nous étions très favorables à l'aide
active à mourir qui avait été mise en
place aussi longtemps que les conditions
qu'avait fixé le législateur ont été
respectées et puis aujourd'hui on en est
à proposer leutasie à des personnes
âgées sans pathologie là nous ne sommes
plus d'accord donc une de nos
recommandations au Parlement humblement
même si je suis ancien parlementaire
consiste à dire surtout soyez
extrêmement précis si vous décidez
effectivement de mettre en place une
aide active à mourir sur les conditions
de façon à ce que la jurisprudence ne
puisse pas aisément les interpréter et
s'il faut revenir ultérieurement parce
que on se rend compte que on ne peut pas
interdire éternellement aux personnes en
situation de handicap mental ou aux
enfants de bénéficier entre guillemets
de de de de de cette aactive à mourir ce
sera au législateur de reprendre
effectivement son travail remettre le
métier sur l'ouvrage et seul lui à mon
avis peut modifier à ce moment-là la la
teneur des questions euh obsession donc
de de de du conseil de la CNSA sur le
problème de des des collaborateurs de de
de l'accompagnement et du soins des
professionnels de l'accompagnement et du
soins aussi longtemps que nous n'aurons
pas le nombre de professionnels de
l'accompagnement et du soins dont nous
avons besoin les meilleurs textes et
même les les meilleurs efforts
financiers ne pourront pas effectivement
donner les résultat que l'on en attend
j'ai j'ai é marqué dans en lisant le
rapport el comomery par une disposition
de de de un petit paragraphe de ce
rapport qui n'a été remis en cause par
personne où elle déclarait il est pas si
si si ancien que ça le rapport alcomery
hein où elle déclarait qu'il faudrait en
en en
2000 25 donc demain il faudrait 350000
collaborateurs supplémentaires si on
voulait pouvoir faire face aux
nécessités liées au au défis
démographiqu ça sachant que cette ce
chiffre impressionnant s'explique aussi
par le turnover extrêmement important
qu'il y a dans ces professions aussi
longemps que ces professions ne seront
pas suffisamment reconnues suffisamment
rémunérées suffisamment organisé et on
se réjouit que dans dans dans dans dans
le projet de loi
sur le financement de la sécurité
sociale il y a un dispositif qui se met
en place qui d'ailleurs avait été prévu
lors du PLFSS précédent c'est ce sont
les 2 heures que l'on baptisait de
convivialité que l'on baptise
aujourd'hui de lien social
qui pourront faire 9h sur sur sur un
mois et qui a non seulement amèneront un
plus important pour les personnes
handicapées et pas pour les personnes
handicapées pour les personnes âgées il
le problème se pose de savoir si
l'extension serait utile vis-à-vis des
personnes handicapées mais il se trouve
que dans la PCH il y a déjà de ce temps
qui était prévu mais non seulement c'est
essentiel de savoir que euh la personne
qui est à leur côté elle peut être à
leur côté non seulement pour procéder à
la toilette pour procéder à à la
préparation des repas pour faire prendre
les repas mais qu'elle peut aussi rester
à leur côté pour discuter avec elle
discuter de de de leur vie de leur
famille de de la prévention qu'il serait
utile qu'ell mettent en place pour les
accompagner si elles peuvent encore le
faire faire le tour de leur jardin si
elles en ont un euh ou les accompagner à
faire quelques courses si c'est dans
leur possibilité mais en plus si vous
voulez de servir c'est c'est vraiment
gagnant gagnant ce dispositif parce que
en plus de servir la personne âgée ça
servira aussi à faire en sorte que les
les les les le travail de de l'aide à
domicile puisse commencer à être très
largement transformé que l'on arrête
d'avoir ces ces personnels de l'aide à
domicile qui sont prises de 2h le matin
2h en fin d'après-midi qui sont payés à
moi j'étais président de département
j'ai demandé combien quel était le
salaire moyen des aides à domicile dans
mon département du Nord qui pas un petit
département 800 € c'est à il faut
vraiment avoir l'esprit de service
public cheviller au corps si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi pour continuer à
travailler dans ces conditionsl pour une
des fonctions les plus nobles qui soit
donc ça aussi c'est notre obsession et
et d'essayer de faire en sorte que non
seulement on est à davantage de
reconnaissance qui s'exprime également
en matière financière des efforts ont
été réalisés d'ailleurs ces derniers
temps sur ce point-là mais que également
on organise des carrières moi je je je
je rêve effectivement à ce que une
personne qui commence comme a à domicile
puisse devenir aide soignante qu'une
aide soignante puisse devenir infirmière
que on les accompagne effectivement dans
la carrière et que pour les personnes
qui n'avaient pas le temps ou n'avaient
pas l'envie de vouloir évoluer dans leur
profession et bien lorsqu'elles prennent
de l'âge on en face des des personnes
ressources on a bien créé beaucoup de
départements ont bien créé des assistant
familial ressources pour permettre
effectivement à leurs jeunes collègues
de de de de de mieux prendre en main
leur travail et d'éviter les choses
trppes dans lesquelles elles-mêm étaient
tombées moi je sais que dans mon
département ça a donné de très bons
résultats je pense que l'aide à domicile
ressource pour des personnes en fin de
carrière ça pourrait être une façon
effectivement de terminer une carrière
de manière très utile et sans avoir
effectivement les les les les les
charges qui sont
inhérentes au niveau également des des
des obsessions du Conseil le le le
problème du logement le problème et là
on va rentrer dans le vif du sujet y
compris sur les épades le problème de de
de de l'accueil des personnes âgées et
notamment des personnes âgées
dépendantes en terme de logement on on a
cassé c'est très bien on a cassé la la
la la le choix le choix drastique et le
choix totalement insupportable entre le
domicile classique et l'Pad beaucoup de
gens ne peuvent plus rester au domicile
parce que le domicile lorsque vous êtes
seul lorsque vous êtes en situation de
dépendance il peut très bien être
mortifère donc ce n'est pas l'alpha et
l'oméga et pourtant ces personnes ne
veulent pas rentrer en épad et et les
les les dérives qui ont
été connues ces C ces dernières années
notamment avec le livre Les fausoyurs
effectivement l'affaire
Orpa qui n'est peut-être que la partie
émergé de lisberg si je peux m'exprimer
ainsi non n'amène pas effectivement à
avoir une envie forte de de rentrer en
épad pour des personnes qui ont encore
leur leur autonomie et puis moi j'avoue
que je me ferai jamais à ce terme d'pad
et établissement d'hébergement pour
personnes âgées dépendantes ça pose
aussi effectivement un problème de d'
d'attractivité si on peut s'exprimer
ainsi se mettre en place des logements
intermédiaires qui sont à mon avis la la
la le le le grand dossier de demain
logement intermédiaires qui peuvent être
des des logements inclusifs qui peuvent
être des logements partagés qui peuvent
être des résidences services
seniors voir l'accueil familial qui qui
peut être développé comme c'est le cas
d'ailleurs dans un certain nombre de
départements et et et j'avoue que
jusqu'à présent chaque fois que je sors
par exemple d'un habitat partagé j'en
sors relativement fier de la politique
de mon pays qu'il s'agisse d'habitat
partagés pour des personnes âgées et
même très âgées ou qu'il s'agisse
d'habitat partagés pour des personnes en
situation de handicap et notamment de
handicap mental j'ai visité il y a pas
si longtemps un habitat partagé pour des
des jeunes alzimer jeunes alzemer c'est
à partir de 45 ans et jusque j'allais
dire 72 par que c'est mon âge si vous
voulez
j'ai rarement vu effectivement un
établissement où des personnes qui
souffrent de ce type de maladie peuvent
mener une vie qui même à nos yeux est
une vie qui
demeure valoir la peine d'être vécu
c'est et je suis convaincu que ce sera
effectivement un développement important
qui devra se faire dans les années à
venir j'étais hier avec l'adjointe au
handicap de la ville de Paris qui
regretter effectivement qu'il n'y ait
pas davantage de de de d'initiativ qui
soi pris et à laquelle j'ai rappelé que
la VP l'aide à la vie partagée était
déjà effectivement un succès pour la 5e
branche de de la sécurité sociale et que
ça se développait effectivement de
manière importante et puis on en vient à
l'Pad on en vient à l'Pad et l'Pad fait
partie de de de des thèmes que la le le
le plfsf nous amène à aborder puisque le
pnfss propose effectivement que on
puisse fusionner les les sections soins
et puis dépendance des éepades mais là
où je suis surpris c'est que c'est à la
carte si je peux m'exprimer ainsi hein
c'est les départements qui en font la
demande on pourra effectivement
fusionner euh je je je je je crains que
cela n'ajoute si vous voulez à un
phénomène qui est un phénomène auquel on
doit remédier qui est l'inégalité du
traitement des personnes en situation de
de de de grande fragilité selon le le
lieu où ils habitent on finira par avoir
des personnes âgées des personnes
handicapés qui choisissent leur domicile
en fonction des politiques
départementales enfin tout ça n n'est
pas acceptable euh et
euh le conseil du SNSA pense qu'il faut
aller plus loin que peut-être le temps
est venu de se poser la question de
savoir si l'épad ne devra pas ne devrait
pas être d'une compétence qui devienne
une compétence totalement nationale mais
pour pour cela il faut il faut être être
clair et et et franchir le mur de de
comment dire de de de l'opacité pour ne
pas dire le mur de l'hypocrisie et et il
faut bien comprendre que aujourd'hui
tous les spécialistes des problèmes
effectivement d'autonomie et Dieu sait
si des rapports sur l'autonomie
important et et aussi remarquable les
uns que les autres ont été publié C ces
dernières années vous disent mais dans
les années à venir et après ils disent
vous savez quand on dit les années à
venir c'est parce qu'on veut être
diplomate c'est très très vite l'Pad
deviendra un lieu de vie pour des
personnes qui sonont soit des personnes
en Girin donc des personnes d'une
extrême dépendance soit des personnes
qui seront en extrême fin de vie il y a
donc une c'est un paradoxe si vous
voulez alors bien sûr aujourd'hui la
situation est en ce qu'elleé les 7500
épades la plupart des des des des
personnes âgées même avec des
dépendances très très encore faibles
sont en épade mais notre notre notre
conviction à la au Conseil de la CNSA
c'est qu'elles n'ont rien à faire en
épade c'est qu'il faudrait effectivement
les les porter dans un habitat
intermédiaire parmi ceux que j'ai cité
tout à l'heure parce que c'est
réellement dans cet habitat
intermédiaire qu'on pourra mettre en
place le le le l'appréhension ce qu'on a
domiciliaire ce qu'on appelait autrefois
le virage domiciliaire mais a tellement
de virage que on se dit que ça va finir
par être dangereux mais bon soit donc ce
virage domiciliaire qui amène
effectivement les personnes qui quittent
leur domicile le quit pour un autre
domicile mais à l'insécurité et la
solitude en moins si on peut s'exprimer
ainsi cela est est parfaitement
pertinent pour l'habitat partagé pour
l'habitat inclusif pour les résidences
seiores si l' pas devient ce lieu de de
de de de fin de vie de très grande
dépendance qui sera à ce moment-là un
lieu effectivement d'une médicalisation
encore beaucoup plus forte qu'elle ne
l'est aujourd'hui c'est pas tellement
dans ce lieu-là qu'on pourra mettre en
place le virage domiciliaire virage
domiciliaire don dont je donne quelques
quelques quelques éléments de de de de
de très concrets de de de la réalisation
le virage domiciliaire ça veut dire que
vous êtes traité comme un citoyen à part
entière j'ai une phrase du président de
cette institution
que qui été mon Président aussi parce
que le les président depuis un moment
donc il y a une phrase que j'aime
beaucoup où Gérard Larché déclare il ne
peut pas y avoir de de citoyenneté en
pointiller dire la citoyenneté c'est
jusqu'au dernier moment de la vie et la
considération comme citoyen c'est
jusqu'au dernier moment de la vie et
bien cela veut dire virage domiciliaire
ça veut dire que si vous avez un animal
familier vous pouvez l'emmener dans le
votre nouveau domicile si vous voulez
recevoir la visite de X Y ou Z
matin après-midi ou soir vous pouvez
avoir la visite de de des gens que vous
avez décidé de voir pardonnez-moi
l'expression mais je veux pas faire
l'économie de de de de ce qui fait
parfois sourire mais si vous avez envie
de passer la nuit avec votre voisine de
chambre et qu'elle on envie de passer la
nuit avec vous et ben c'est votre droit
le plus strict et vous n'avez pas à
avoir les remarques déplacées qui
peuvent parfois être faites à ce à ce
niveau-là et bien sûr vous êtes des
citoyens donc au moment des élections il
est essentiel que vous ayez et je
pourrais le dire également pour les
personnes en situation de handicap dont
on a reconnu plus largement le droit de
vote que vous ayez la possibilité
d'avoir des explications claires nettes
qui soient faites pour que vous puissiez
choisir en toute connaissance de cause
les personnes pour lesquelles
effectivement vous voulez accorder votre
confiance euh bon voilà ce ce ce ce
cadre est en posé je dire deux mots
simplement sur le le l'avis qui a été
rendu par mais vous l'avez cet avis qui
a été rendu par la CNSA la CNSA a rendu
un avis euh où elle a pris acte à la
majorité effectivement de de de de
autrement dit elle ne s'est pas prononcé
pas pour ou contre mais les voix contre
ont été plus importantes que les voix
pour elle a pris acte de de de dans un
premier vote de la présentation du
projet de loi de financement de sécurité
sociale pour 2024 alors vous savez que
il y a il y a deux votes de la CNSA euh
enfin il y a eu deux votes cette fois-ci
en tout cas du Conseil pardon du conseil
de la CNS m dir général tout à fait il y
a un vote sur la nature de la vie donc
la vie c'est une prise d'acte et il y a
un vote à bon viis incomparablement plus
important c'est sur les motivations de
la vie sur les motivations de la vie le
vote a été unanime vous avez
effectivement les motivation de la vie
et c'est cela qui vous intéressera et
c'est cel de cela dont on discutera j'ai
vu les questions qui qui vont être
posées
et là-dessus on a réuni encore une fois
la totalité des membres du conseil
monsieur le Président merci Madame la
Directrice quelques mots et puis ensuite
on va passer assez rapidement aux
question merci monsieur le Président euh
bonjour à toutes et à tous je salue
spécialement la nouvelle rapporteur de
la branche autonomie et que vraiment
nous accueillerons avec un très grand
plaisir euh à la CNSA si vous le
souhaitez pour vous présenter plus
concrètement euh nos collaborateurs et
le fonctionnement de l'équipe juste
quelques mots de comp texte
et pour insister sur plusieurs points au
moment où mesdames messieurs vous
démarrez l'examen de ce projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale qui
comporte comme depuis la création de la
branche autonomie qui vous permet
d'avoir un regard d'ensemble sur les
financements apportés par cette branche
dans l'effort de la nation en faveur du
soutien à l'autonomie vous avez une
annexe 7 au PLFSS qui est nouvelle qui
est associée à la création de la branche
et qui vous permet dans le même temps
d'apprécier l'ampleur de cet effort qui
conjugue des financements de l'état des
département dont le président du Conseil
a rappelé qu'ils étaient représentés au
sein du conseil de la CNSA et des
financements majoritaires de la sécurité
sociale et au sein d'entre eux de la
branche autonomie alors ce projet de loi
de financement de sécurité sociale pour
2024 vous permettra de valider de voter
le tableau d'équilibre de la branche en
recette et en dépenses c'est une faculté
nouvelle qui est offerte au législateur
depuis la création de la branche et je
le redis qui vous permet d'avoir une
vision globale de notre intervention
alors qu'avant la création de la branche
vous étiez invité à vous prononcer sur
une partie seulement de nos recettes au
travers de ce qu'on appelait alors
l'ONDAM l'objectif de dépenses
d'assurance maladie désormais c'est une
vision globale des recettes je l'ai dit
et en particulier vous le savez euh de
la recette de CSG qui est affecté au
financement euh de du soutien aux
personnes âgées au personnes handicapées
des recettes dont vous noterez qu'elles
sont dynamique puisque en 2024 euh le
PLFSS j'allais dire tient la promesse
faite aux personnes âgées aux personnes
handicapées à la création de la branche
dans le contexte du vote de la loi
organique qui a créé cette branche et
qui a prévu l'affectation dès 2024 d'un
ressaut d'une part complémentaire de CSG
pour accompagner le la transition
démographique à laquelle fait face notre
pays et son vieillissement donc le
premier
prier le premier point important de
cette loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2024 c'est je le redis la
mise en œuvre de la promesse d'une
solidarité
accrue en direction des personnes é des
personnes handicapées des
professionneles qui les accompagnent
avec ce ressaut de financement qui
représente une progression des recettes
de 12 % entre 2023 et
2024 ce ressut de financement il est
tout à fait le bienvenu face aux besoins
très importants
de qui ont été et aux attentes qui ont
notamment été exprimées par le président
du conseil aux attentes des personnes de
leurs proches des professionnels qui les
accompagn de davantage d'accompagnement
et d'un accompagnement qui se transforme
dans le sens qui a été évoqué
c'est-à-dire qui permettent un
accompagnement plus soutenant plus
individualisé qui favorise le maintien à
domicile qui soit historique ou qu'il
s'agisse de ces nouvelles proposition de
logement sécurisé sans nécessairement
requérir toute la médicalisation des
épades même si le président l' encore la
rappelé et le rapport avait le Sénat
avait adopté un rapport important sur le
devenir des épades dans le cadre de la
précédente
mandature nous savons aussi qu' il faut
accompagner l'évolution du modèle des
éepad je veux souligner que dans les
dépenses plus importantes qui sont
permis donc par cette trajectoire de
recette
positive l'année 2024 donc va permettre
d'enregistrer une progression de
dépenses de + 5,2 % par rapport à 2023
pour atteindre
39,9 milliards d'euros et vous l'aurez
vous pourrez le constater la trajectoire
euh financière de la branche et
dynamique le ressaut de recette de CSG
permettant d'accompagner donc une
dynamique forte projetée à horizon de
2027 jusqu'à près de 45 milliards
d'euros le président l'a évoqué et j'y
insiste c'est cette progression des
financements publics vise évidemment
accompagner les besoins de personnes
âgées plus nombreuses avec le
vieillissement de la population mais
vise aussi à accompagner une
transformation de l'offre aussi bien sur
le champ du
handicap et vous le savez il y a de
nombreux fin connaisseurs de la question
commencer par le président de la
Commission dans cette salle l'offre à
destination des personnes handicapées se
transformment et se transforment
rapidement j'en ai vu un exemple très
concret en allant dans votre département
monsieur le
Président il se transforme donc cette
offre d'accompagnement se transforme
aussi dans le chandelage et je veux
souligner que d'un strict point de vue
financier permettez-moi de l'adopter
puisque je dirige une caisse de sécurité
sociale lorsqu'on
regarde la la courte période qui nous
sépare de la création de la branche
2021-2023 nous voyons que le surcroix de
financement qui ont été mobilisé depuis
la création de la Caisse a
été comment dire à bénéfici
beaucoup plus au à l'organisation et au
soutien des personnes à leur domicile
qu'en
établissement lorsqu'on regarde
l'ensemble des financements qui appuient
le financement des services d'aide à
domicile au travers des différents
concours de la caisse en lien bien sûr
avec la mise en place des mesures qui
ont été votées dans les deux précédentes
PLFSS dans les deux précédentes pardon
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale notamment la mise en place d'un
tarif plancher notamment la mise en
place une dotation qualité et bien le
total du soutien de la Caisse en lié à
ses prestations individuelle à la
revalorisation de la branche de l'aide à
domicile représente une augmentation de
39 % de nos financements alors même que
le soutien j'allais dire aux autres
établissements a été évidemment très
dynamique sous l'effet en particulier
des revalorisation du segéur mais
s'élève à un peu moins de 12 %. donc on
voit que vraiment la création de la
branche j'allais dire commence de tenir
des promesses qui ont été faites un
effort un soutien de la solidarité
nationale renforcé et des une capacité à
intervenir
davantage pour le garantir la capacité
notamment des personnes âgées à vieillir
chez ell en en sécurité trois éléments
sans vouloir être beaucoup plus longues
et je pense que la réponse aux questions
permettra de les compléter si vous m'en
laissez le loisir pour vous assurer
d'une part que dans le tableau
d'équilibre de la branche et comme vous
le voyez à travers une des dispositions
de la loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale ce projet de loi va permettre de
commencer de mettre en œuvre les mesures
de la très importante conférence
nationale du handicap qui s'est tenue au
printemps dernier et qui vise notamment
à organiser un rattrapage massif dans
les territoires les plus en tension en
matière d'accompagnement des personnes
handicapées avec un plan de création de
50000 solutions un premier une première
tranche de crédit est inscrite dans les
dépenses de la branche pour commencer
d'avancer dans cette direction 2024 et
d'autre
part également pour ce pour soutenir
pardon la mise en place du service de
repérage et d'accompagnement précoce qui
trouve sa base juridique dans le texte
même de la
LFSS et puis souligner encore en écho
évidemment à l'attention très grande du
conseil sur la situation des
professionnels que les financements
apportés par la par le PLFSS pour 2024
vont permettre de poursuivre et
d'amplifier le soutien au professionnel
qui passe d'abord bien sûr par le
soutien à la rémunération des
professionnels plus de 4 milliards
d'euros depuis 2020 en lien avec les
mesures Segur la revalorisation des
professionnels c'est s sans équivalent
euh et puis le soutien à la
modernisation de l'offre notamment avec
des mesures d'investissement importante
voilà je veux également souligner que
nous continuons de travailler c'est le
cœur de notre feuille de route et de
notre COG euh au au au progrès de
l'équité de traitement des personnes
notamment en réfléchissant et apportant
notre contribution à l'émergence d'un
service public départemental euh de de
l'autonomie et en réfléchissant et en
travaillant à une possible réforme des
concours que la caisse a loue au
département pour mieux les soutenir dans
l'exercice de leur responsabilité je
suis évidemment disponible pour répondre
aussi à vos questions sur ces sujets
merci
beaucoup Madame la Directrice merci
monsieur le Président on va tout de
suite passer donc aux premières
questions et je vais donner la parole à
notre rapporteur Chantal
desen merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Madame la direct
vous avez balayé déjà un certain nombre
de points je voudrais vous faire
préciser quelques points en particulier
en premier lieu sur cette enveloppe de
100 millions d'euros pour venir aux
établissements en
difficulté est-ce que cette cette
enveloppe a déjà été versée aux
s est-ce que vous pouvez nous préciser
quels sont les critères ou dans quelles
conditions cette enveloppe peut-elle
être mobilisée et est-ce que cela vous
semble suffisant est-ce que ça aura
vraiment un impact sur la situation de
ces
établissements j'ai entamé les les
auditions en début de semaine et on nous
disait hier que 50 % des établissement
étit
fragilisé voilà concernant l'objectif
global des dépenses vous l'avez signalé
qui est en augmentation mais d'après
vous est-ce que
cette ce ce rythme est cohérent avec la
promesse qui a été faite de 50000
solutions nouvell d'ici 2030
euh au niveau de l'article 40 38 pardon
avec le le
repérage des
enfants handicap ou présentant des
difficultés on sait actuellement que les
centres d'action médicauxsociaux
précoces ont un petit peu de mal à
remplir le leurs objectifs et qu'il y a
une file
d'attente est-ce que
malgré cette nouvelle mesure de 44
millions d'euros fléchés on va pouvoir
répondre aux besoins et absorber la file
d'attente vous avvez évoqué aussi la
fusion des sections soins et dépendance
qui était préconisé dans de nombreux
rapports monsieur le Président vous y
avez en partie répondu puisque
effectivement se pose le le risque qu'il
y ait une différenciation de traitement
selon les les départements donc euh en
plus vous l'avez rappelé c'est à la
carte euh c'est un choix qui est
définitif euh ne pensez-vous pas qu'il
aurait peut-être été souhaitable comme
le préconisaient certains rapports qu'il
y ait une
expérimentation avant de le mettre en
place sans qu'il y ait de retour poss
possible pour les départements et puis
peut-être une une peut-être une une
certaine réserve des
départements pour ce pour aller vers
cette fusion parce qu'on ne sait pas
bien encore
comment qui aura la gouvernance comment
dans quelles conditions et cetera
euh le je voudrais revenir aussi sur
l'ofre des services d'aide à
domicile qui passe entre autres par une
une réforme de leur financement quel
bilan faites-vous de la mise en place
d'un tarif plancher national pour ces
services et pouvez-vous évaluer l'impact
de cette mesure sur le reste à charge
des départements d'une part mais aussi
sur le reste à charge des usagers ou
résidents je vous
remercie je vous laisse répondre je sais
pas qui commence on va s'organiser
ensemble sans trop de difficultés on en
a un peu
l'habitude sur le premier point le
premier point sur la les les fameuses
100 millions ces 100 millions sont
considérés effectivement j'allais dire
bien évidemment comme drisoire par
rapport effectivement à la demande qui
était faite puisque les 100 millions
concernent à la fois le problème des
épades et le problème effectivement des
services à domicile et puis ce qui me
paraît effectivement regrettable si vous
voulez c'est que ça se se
renouvelle juste avant les vacances
chaque année c'est-à-dire que chaque
année il y a effectivement lors du
conseil de juin ou de juillet les les
les alertes qui sont faites par les
présidents des fédérations par exemple
d'aide à domicile les les représentants
également des éepades pour dire B voilà
s'il ne se passe rien nous mettons la
Cais sous la porte ce n'est plus
possible on n'y arrive plus donc donc on
prend
notre notre bâton de pèlerin on va au
ministère et on dit ministère c'est plus
possible lequel ministère nous dit bon
ben on va dégager effectivement des
crédits d'urgence et là on a dégagé 100
millions effectivement de crédit
d'urgence
bon nous souhaiterions effectivement ne
plus avoir jamais ou presque de crédit
d'urgence à distribuer mais qu'il y ait
effectivement des réformes structurelles
qui
permettent quelquefois difficile
certainement à accepter pour pour
certains mais qui permett effectivement
de de ne plus vivre de cette manière-là
en outre vous avez aujourd'hui des des
éléments conjoncturels c'est-à-dire les
épades sont moins remplis aujourd'hui
qu'il était hier moi j'ai des présidents
de département qui me disent je
souhaiterais fermer euh tel nombre
d'épad AC qui je réponds mais il faut
pas fermer les épades mais peut-être les
transformer transformer ces épades en
résidences servic personnes âgées et à
ce qui nécessite effectivement des
travaux et des travaux relativement
important vous savez ce qu'on appelait
autrefois les foyers logement qui
aujourd'hui on en parle avec un peu de
de de de commissération c'était une
façon effectivement de pouvoir maintenir
une vie qui soit qui soit sociale qui
soit qui soit intéressante qui qui
laisse effectivement beaucoup plus
d'initiative aux personnes que elles ne
peuvent l'avoir aujourd'hui on est pas
et je pense qu'il faut les repenser pour
les les les les actualiser en fonction
des besoins d'aujourd'hui donc sur sur
ces 100 millions après la distribution
euh Virginie vous vous vous en parlera
sur le votre remarque sur
le le soin le le le tarif plancher le
tarif plancher c'était une très bonne
chose que d'avoir un tarif plancher mais
moi j'ai toujours regretté les modalités
avec lesquelles il s'est mis en place d'
ce tarif planché qui a consisté
effectivement à passer à 22 € dans un
premier temps euh alors que certains
départements étaient à 16 ou 17 il s'est
il a laissé dans dans les départements
une amertume considérable une amertume
considérable tout simplement parce que
la décision de compenser à l'intégralité
elle a abouti très souvent à financer
des département parmi les plus aisés
pour ne pas dire parmi les plus riches
des départements quand les Alpes
Maritimes pour qui c'est un véritable
pactol et c'est c'est un effet d'obben
qui se renouvelle année après année
alors que des départements beaucoup
moins riches avaient fait l'effort de se
mettre d'ors et déjà au 22 € parce que
leur population en avait effectivement
absolument besoin et cela ma fois on les
oublie tranquillement en se disant bon
ils y étaient tant pis pour eux il y a
pas de compensation à faire le le je
souhaiterais si vous voulez que à
l'occasion de de de de la refonte sur
laquelle je reste un peu sceptique de la
refonte des dotations de la CNSA de
l'État au au au au département on puisse
mettre fin à ce système effectivement
ement qui est un système qui a se se
transforme d'année en année en effet d'
ben pour un chiffrage de l'ordre de 300
millions quand même c'est pas rien la
compensation al je disais un jour où
j'étais de mauvaise humeur vous faites
du Robin des Bois à l'envers vous prenez
effectivement au pauvres pour donner aux
riches sur sur bon c'était pas juste
puisque la la tarif plancher il est
important il est important qu'il soit à
22 bon il y a il y a un certain
déséquilibre dans la sitation situation
des
départements je pense qu'il faudra
effectivement le le revoir ce problème
là d'autre part les les les 22 € étant
insuffisant sont passés à 23 il y a les
3 € de de qui peuvent être donnés en
complémentarité effectivement par la
CNSA il faudrait peut-être que sur ce
point-là on élargisse la possibilité
parce que 20 23 + 3 m connaissances
mathématiqu pe permettre de dire que ça
fait 26 et on s'approche un peu à la
fois de ce qui est serait considéré par
les grandes fédérations comme étant le
tarif auquel elles peuvent elles peuvent
s'ajuster sur le le soin et la de la
dépendance vous avez parlé
d'expérimentation alors là je je prends
je prendrai une tournure optimiste en
disant moi je considère comme une
expérimentation mais c'est peut-être pas
exactement ce que dit le législateur il
faudrait que ce soit interprété comme
une expérimentation parce que sinon ça
n'a pas de sens laissz effectivement
dans un pays où vous avez des politiques
qui sont aussi différ entre où on se bat
effectivement pour
avoir à la fois le maintien de de la
spécificité départementale mais l'octro
de de d'aide qui soit comparable dans
des situations comparables du nord au
sud et de l'est à l'ouest là vous allez
créer effectivement des des des
disparités supplémentaires qui
n'existaient pas moi je serais beaucoup
plus favorable à ce qu'il y ait une
solution qui soit une solution globale
le passage à la compétence de de de de
l'État en contrepartie d'ailleurs que
les départements voi réaffirmer leurs
compétences sur tout ce qui est domicile
au sens ancien et au sens nouveau du
terme parce que je crois que la
proximité elle est extrêmement utile
pour le domicile elle est extrêmement
utile pour les alternatives au domicile
et puis si les pas devient un lieu
d'extrême fin de vie c'est il est normal
que la médicalisation y soit ce qu'elle
doit être je signale également que dans
dans dans dans dans dans cette extrême
fin de vie on retrouve le problème
effectivement de de de la réforme de la
fin de vie en France et et on y retrouve
aussi des raisons supplémentaires de se
préoccuper des problèmes de personnel
moi toutes les personnes que j'ai pu
auditer dans les épades par exemple
épades qui avaient mis en place des des
des des des des des systèmes innovants
des épades où ils avaient commencé si je
peux m'exprimer ainsi à réapprivoiser la
mort à faire comprendre que la mort elle
faisait partie de la vie et que on il
fallait cesser de la cacher cesser de
cacher effectivement le le le cercueil
de la personne personne qui va
partir le faire partir la nuit sans que
personne ne s'en rende
compte certains épades ont mis en place
des groupes de paroles sur la mort qui
ont beaucoup de succès auprès des
résidents ont décidé par exemple que
lorsque une personne décédé elle plutôt
que de cacher son cercueil il y avait
une sorte de ha d'onneur qui était faite
lorsqu'il quittait effectivement l'Pad
que quelques jours plus tard ont
retrouva les voisins les la famille les
voisins de chambre les amis dans
une manifestation que je qualifieraiis
de conviviale où il y a le le les les
photos effectivement du défunt où chacun
rappelle la vie qu'il a pu avoir les
souvenirs qu'il a eu auprès du défunt et
chacun sait que lorsqu'il partira il ne
partira pas comme un voleur mais qu'il
partira effectivement dans dans la plus
grande
sérénité alors quelques compléments sur
vos vos cinq ation en essayant d'être
rapide comment est-ce que le les crédits
de la CNSA ont été alloués aux ARS ils
ont été notifiés donc les ARS
connaissent leurs enveloppes ces crédits
sont constitué par un abonnement des
dotations au Fonds d'intervention
régionaux ils seront effectivement payés
fin octobre ils doivent permettre
d'aller vite et d'aller d'autant plus
vite que je veux le souligner l'ensemble
des agences régionales se sont mobilisés
conformément au terme d'abord de de
l'instruction du 29 septembre
et de la demande de la ministre Aurore
verger
de mettre en place les commissions
départementales qui vont être les lieux
de
supervision des situations critiques
l'ensemble des ARS donc se sont
mobilisés conjointement avec les
services des directions départementales
des finances publiques qui sont qui ont
vocation à coprésider ces commissions en
sorte que les commissions
départementales qui seront je le redis
le lieu d'appréciation des difficultés
soit toutes installées début octobre et
elle était dans l'ensemble des
départements euh c'est donc bien dans
ces commissions qui sont constitué
autour j'allais dire du noyau dur des
agences régionales de santé et des
Direction départementale des finances
publiques et qui associe à titre
principal le représentant le président
du conseil départemental l'URSAF les
spam la banque des territoires donc
l'ensemble des financeurs et des
institutions qui on qui ont sont en
capacité d'apporter une appréciation sur
la situation économique des structures
que les situations ont vocation à être
examiné et à être soutenu le cas échéant
par les crédits du fond euh le président
soulignit que ces fonds avaient tendance
à se renouvel je veux dire que c'est la
première fois s'agissant des éepades et
cette création elle fait écho à la
situation effectivement difficile que
vous évoquez qui est caractérisée
également par une autre annexe des ESMS
portant sur la situation économique des
établissements sanitaires et
médicosx-sociaux qui relèv que les
comptes d'un certain nombre des de ces
établissements se sont dégradés à la
fois sous des effets structurels qu'a
évoqué le président peut-être une crise
de confiance euh dans le modèle éepad
après la crise Orpa après la crise covid
mais également des raisons tout à fait
conjoncturelles qui tiennent à
l'inflation à la au coût des matières
premières et aussi aux difficultés et
aux tensions sur le marché de l'emploi
aux difficultés à recruter des
professionnels qui font qu'on voit dans
le secteur médico-social ce que connaît
malheureusement le secteur sanitaire
depuis de nombreuses années c'est-à-dire
la difficulté à recruter de manière
pérenne le recours à l'intérim avec euh
j'allais dire le renchérissement très
conséquent euh du des masses salariales
associé à ce recours à l'intérim en se
souvenant que suivant les structures ces
masses salariales c'est 75 à 80 % du
budget des établissements donc bien sûr
que ces fonds ils ont vocation à être
mobilisés tout de suite ils sont
disponibles ils viendront aussi ils ont
vocation à venir en complément de
l'ensemble des aides de droits communs
qui peuvent être mobilisés et c'est pour
ça que la ministre a tenu les ministres
ont tenu à ce que les ursav la des
finances publiques puissent être
présenté pour recourir aussi au
dispositifs j'allais dire tout à fait
usuel dans le casre des situations
difficilees étalement de dett social et
fiscal voilà dans une appréciation
globale les commissions auront vocation
à soutenir un réétablissement pérenn
avec une a d'urgence mobilisée en tant
que de besoins complément des
dispositifs de droit commun et suivre la
mise en œuvre du rétablissement vous
m'interrogez alors vous avez évoqué la
question du repérage et de du niveau de
rhaussement des dotations des des cams
je souscris avec vous au constat que les
besoins que les moyens de
l'accompagnement des jeunes enfants 0 6
ans au moment de la détection et surtout
pour augmenter la capacité
d'intervention précoce à un moment où
les cerveaux sont plastiques et où cette
intervention euh le plus intense
possible au bon moment et susceptible
vraiment de de de de faire la différence
sur euh la capacité du jeune enfant à se
rapprocher de courbes de développement
plus usuel et donc on sait c'est
l'acquis he de la précédente stratégie
autisme et l'objectif de la nouvelle
disposition c'est d'élargir cette
capacité de repérage de détection et
d'intervention précoce sur un spectre
très large de situation de handicap on
sait que ce cette intervention elle est
cruciale c'est la raison donc pour
laquelle ces financements sont alloués
les cams doivent être renforcés mais euh
la création de ce service fera appel
aussi à d'autres professionnels et donc
va mobiliser l'offre en libéral euh et
donc voilà c'est évidemment les crédits
pour les cams mais aussi les crédits
portés par euh la branche maladie avec
l'intervention de professionnels qui ont
vocation à être conjugué pour apporter
le niveau
la capacité à intervenir dans les
territoires sur ce repérage et cette
intervention précoce je me permet d'ter
un mot sur ce cet aspect qui tenait
vraiment très à cœur au Conseil de la
CNSA puisque nous en avions fait la
recommandation lors de la Conférence
nationale du handicap et Madame Darios
avait nous avait dit qu'elle ferait en
sorte qu'il y ait effectivement des des
des dispositions dans la loi de
financement et c'est le cas qui a aille
dans ce sens moi j'avais rencontré de
nombreux directeurs et directrices de
camps qui m'avait tous donner le le le
le même message le message c'était le
fait que ils étaient occupés à 150 % si
je peux m'exprimer ainsi qu'ils étaient
incapables de faire face à ce qu'on leur
demandait que aujourd'hui ils ne
voyaient plus dans beaucoup de
départements que les enfants de moins de
3 ans c'est-à-dire que enfant de 3 à 6
ans il n'y avait plus effectivement
d'attention qui leur été porté parce
qu'il ne pouvaient plus le faire et que
ils avaient absolument besoin d'avoir un
un renchérissement de leurs moyens pour
qu' puisse tenter d'avoir des
collaborateurs supplémentaires
aujourd'hui ils sont tous très contents
de cette évolution et ils s'interrogent
sur un autre point c'est va-t-on trouver
alors c'est sûr que les libéraux
pourront venir à la rescosse mais
va-t-on trouver effectivement les
personnels en nombre suffisant pour
venir les aider dans leur tâche et et
tous me disait il y a des des des des
types de handicap sur lesquels si
l'enfant est pris très tôt il n'y a plus
de handicap du tout et lorsque ce n'est
pas le cas le handicap qu' dont il
souffrira sera sans commune mesure avec
celui dont dont il aurait souffert s'il
n'y avait pas eu de prévention précoce
je crois donc que c'est une mesure
mesure essentielle et c'est une mesure
qui sur la durée sera une mesure qui a
ne coûtera rien je Seris tenté de dire
au contribuable bien au contraire parce
que c'est c'est une mesure qui certes
au-delà des des des des des des du
calendrier des des échéances électorales
amènera effectivement des progrès
considérables très bien Virginie vous
terminez parce que là on on est dans le
dans le temps là très très serré donc
allez-y euh trois mots
sur la mise en œuvre du tarif national
plancher on est en train de mettre la
main avec le ministère
à à la préparation d'un d'un d'un
rapport plus complet qui rendra compte
des conditions de son déploiement je
veux souligner que même s'il y a des
questions sur les conditions de la
compensation par la CNSA du surcût
associé au au département c'est une
mesure qui a fait
l'unanimité le fait de permettre de sol
is mieux cette intervention à domicile
et de tendre avec surtout si le tarif
plancher complété de la dotation
complémentaire un tarif horaire qui se
rapproche
de de coût qui avait été observé en
amont de l'introduction de cette réforme
lors d'étude de coû
conduite dans les années 1920 et même si
ces coûts depuis se sont renchéris c'est
une mesure qui est simple et qui est
équitable euh c'est un tarif plancher
identique dans l'ensemble du territoire
je veux souligner sa simplicité et son
caractère très lisible parce que si il y
a bien quelque chose qui manque dans
l'organisation et le financement de
l'aide à domicile c'est sa lisibilité
vous le savez bien contenu des
différences de statut conttenu des
différences de tarification conttenu des
différences de financement donc ce
premier pas euh me semble un effort très
important pour garantir euh une
solvabilisation à meilleur niveau de
l'in intervention des professionnels à
domicile et derrière Jean-René leer a
rappelé les conditions de rémunération
de professionnels qui sont souvent à
temps partiel de garantir enfin une
meilleure rétribution de ces
professionnels donc nous mettons la main
au à la à la rédaction de ce rapport qui
permettra de de répondre
sur le le reste à charge pour les
départements évidemment le tarif
plancher sa mise en œuvre a été compensé
intégralement c'était l'engagement euh
ce à quoi nous souscrivons c'est que la
compensation de cette dépense
particulière au sein de financement très
importants qui sont alloués à l'aide à
domicile puisque désormais nous avons
pas moins de h concours huit suyaux
financiers différents qui partent de la
CNSA vers les départements pour
solvabiliser une seule et même chose
l'intervention à domicile ça c'est trop
compliqué ce n'est pas lisible ça ne
permet pas d'intervenir correctement et
donc il faut le simplifier
très bien alors vous êtes 12 à vouloir
intervenir et les réponses qui trop
court alors voilà ce que je vous propose
c'est que globalement on respecte pas
plus d'une minute pour les questions pas
plus d'une minute pour les réponses et
dans l'éventualité où ça déborde on vous
enverra on demandera des réponses
écrites pour les dernières intervenants
voilà très bien alors je va commencer
par Frédéric là vous avez l'impression
hein Frédéric puissap chrono non
simplement je je voulais réinvenir sur
les sur les Sades parce
qu'effectivement on sait que ce sont des
des modèles qui sont en pleine mutation
d'un point de vue financier d'un point
de vue organisation euh par contre on
constate quand même et et moi je prends
l'exemple du département lisère que je
connais bien que depuis un certain temps
on a eu quand même une augmentation de
la tarification euh dans lesires nous
sommes passés quand nous avons eu la
convergence des tarifs en gros de 17 à
27 € euh donc on a effectivement une
augmentation de de la tarification mais
pour autant on a parfois le sentiment
que ça ruisselle pas jusqu'au bout et en
l'occurrence jusque aux professionnels
qui comme vous le dites ont un salaire
moyen qui qui n'est pas acceptable euh
quand quand on entend vos propos donc ma
question nous dans le département Lisa
nous avons fait le choix de lancer un
audit sur l'intégralité des Sades donc
deux questions est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
départements qui sont dans ce cas-là et
est-ce qu'il y a pas un sujet modèle de
sad au-delà de l'aspect financier merci
Daniel
Chassin merci monsieur le Président donc
en ce qui me concerne donc très
rapidement deux ou trois questions
concernant la fin de vie des personnes
âgées il faut pas arriver comme au
Pays-Bas si vous voulez à ce qu'il y ait
des personnes sans pathologie
qui et bien prennent la solution
d'active à mourir il faut ne faut-il pas
avoir renforcé beaucoup les soins
palliatifs avant de prendre d'autres
d'autres décisions
deuxièmement
les les personnes les les les personnes
âgées en épad vont les personnes âgées
de plus de 85 ans vont doubler d'ici
2040 il faut bien sûr conserver les
épades mais il faut renforcer le
personnel en épad Madame la Directrice
je vous rappelle que dans le pdfss il y
a 6000 emplois de plus ça fait même pas
un emploi par épad et actuellement on a
un GMP très élevé il faut donc avoir au
moins progressivement 50000 emplois dans
les dans les épad ça fait 5 emplois par
épad plus plus 10000 emplois pour
renforcer les SIAD ne faut-il pas faire
cela très rapidement et renforcer les
résidences autonomie pour pour ne pas
avoir à augmenter les épades pour ne pas
avoir à augmenter les les épades on peut
toujours faire des commissions mais
c'est le financement qui est important
et je voudrais remercier monsieur le
Président qui connaît bien le problème
merci merci alors le texte sujet fin de
vie n'est pas dans le texte hein donc on
passe sur les autres sujets alors
corbert très bien alors Elisabeth
devanau
oui alors moi je vais insister sur
l'inquiétude des territoires par rapport
à l'état des éepades c'est vrai que
c'est pas un très joli nom je vous
l'accorde en tout cas c'est comme ça que
ça s'appelle aujourd'hui donc on
continue à prendre le même
dénominatif une grande inquiétude des
des élus locaux parce qu'ils sont
souvent dans dans la gouvernance he les
maires et donc il voit bien la
montée de l'inflation l'alimentation
l'énergie comme vous dites le recours à
l'intérim qui coûte aussi beaucoup et je
pense que les 100 millions d'euros ne
suffiront pas euh à à à à comment
dirais-je oui 10 millions par
département comme tu le dis c'est pas
suffisant et moi ce que je crains c'est
que en fait et bien comme dans certains
établissements d'ailleurs pour personnes
handicapées c'est que les directeurs
d'établissement fassent des choix entre
les personnes qui arrivent c'est-à-dire
que ceux qui sont les plus vulnérables
qui sont à l'aide sociale ben on va pas
forcément les prendre si les tarifs sont
pas suffisamment hauts donc en fait ça
c'est un vrai drame un vrai drame et
pour les personnes handicapées moi j'ai
eu l'emple exemple par exemple de
parents qui ont mis leur jeune fils de
18 ans dans un établissement et donc qui
avait fait comment dirais je même pas
lesffes mais enfin qui avaient toujours
eu leur leur fils à la maison mais pour
lui donner plus d'autonomie donc l'ont
inscrit dans un établissement et le fait
est que l'établissement n'a pas voulu
dans un premier temps facee faire de
l'accueil séquentiel alors que les
parents auraient souhaité qu'il s'adapte
petit à petit parce que justement les
financements sont pas suffisants pour
faire cet accueil il préférait que le
jeune euh et bien reste couché tous les
soirs et ça c'est inacceptable ces choix
euh que que que font les directeurs
faute de pouvoir faire autrement et pour
les personnes les familles c'est
épouvantable et puis un dernier point
c'est l'ingénierie comment les petits
établissements parce que moi je je prône
pour les petits établissements dans les
territoires ruraux aux plus proches des
familles des voisins des personnes que
les personnes âgées ont connu et bien
ces petits établissement répondent à
l'attente mais seulement ils sont
dépourvus d'ingénierie et qu'est-ce que
vous proposez pour les accompagner merci
Justine guidez
oui merci président moi je vrais revenir
sur les PCO le suivi est fait pour les
enfants de 0 ou 6 ans qu'en est-il pour
les enfants de 7 12 ans je crois qu'il y
avait une demande assez importante
là-dessus sachant que aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que les PCO ne fonctionnent pas
malheureusement très bien puisqueil y a
un manque de professionnel et et c'est
compliqué par rapport à leur
rémunération autre sujet vite fait le
recrutement des aides à domicile euh
vous savez que dans les territoires
ruraux c'est très compliqué notamment
parce que c'est un secteur je dirais
assez défavorisé et ils ont des
problèmes pour ne seraitce se payer le
permis de conduire et la voiture après
donc que faire est-ce qu'il y a pas un
moyen aussi pour les aider là-dessus
autrement on va tourner en rond on
avavancera pas et ensuite les aidants il
y a une mise en place une
expérimentation du baluchonnage ou répi
dans 24 départements et j'ai entendu
dire que alors que ça fonctionne très
très bien qui pourrait être qui ne
serait pas pérénisé voilà qu'en est-il
merci Jean-Luc
ficher oui merci Monsieur le le
Président je crois que le constat il est
unanime on est dans une situation qui
est absolument désastreuse pour le monde
des personnes âgées et du handicap alors
moi je voudrais témoigner de deux
situations il y a un collectif de M des
côtes d'ARM Mor finisterère ensemble qui
se réunissent régulièrement pour
identifier leurs problèm d'pad et qui
aujourd'hui se donneent des marge à 3
mois à 3 mois ils disent une situation
absolument catastrophique j'ai rencontré
il y a 8 jours les Président et
Directeur d'association du secteur
médico-social ils disent ne plus pouvoir
investir avir des coups de
fonctionnement qui augmentent et et pour
certains dans le privé solidaire en
situation de dépôt de bilan donc ma
question elle est très simple la
situation elle est désastreuse comment
faire pour que le PLFSS 2023 ne soit pas
simplement despansements sur des jambes
de bois 100 millions des des des des
abondements d'urgence comme ça ça
correspond à rien pour le Finistère rien
que pour les épades c'est 30 millions
Aurore berger est venu autre jour a dit
je vous accorde au département 10
millions c'est catastrophique c'est
catastrophique il y a vraiment urgence
et je veux le dire avec force vraiment
avec force merci très bien je vous
laisse répondre à cette première série
de questions vous avez 6
minutes
quelques quelques éléments si vous
voulez de réponse sur le le le
l'ingéerie par exemple que que que vous
signaliez qui est qui est un vrai
problème c'est moi je sais également
qu'il y a des problèmes d'ingénierie que
rencontre en milieu rural les directeurs
de de de de d'pad lorsqu'ils ont des des
projets de reconstruction par exemple
ils ont pas été formés ce genre de chos
là il y a un élément il y a une solution
qui serait une solution très facile qui
permettrait également d'ailleurs au
département de s'investir et je pense
qu'il serait heureux de le faire puisque
tous les départements ont mis en place
ce qu'on appelle généralement des
agences techniques départementales ils
ont même rénové ces agences techniques
départementales moi je l'avais fait en
créant des des des des des des des
structures qui a leur permettent de
mettre à disposition gracieusement des
techniciens auprès des communes et je
sais que cette cette initiative ne
rencontre pas tout le succès qu'elle
mériterait de rencontrer parce que les
gens les les les les les communes
hésitent à les saisir il faudrait
élargir cette compétence aux EPAD euh si
c'est un épad je prends les exemples
chez moi sur l'île c'est pas la peine
parce qu'il y a des services nécessaires
dans une ville importante en revanche
les les les épades dans les dans les
petites communes qui sont d'ailleurs
généralement ceux où la qualité de vie
est supérieure hein ceuxl ils ont ils
n'ont pas le personnel effectivement
d'accompagnement ce personnel il existe
dans les structures départementales et
généralement nous on avait fait un
sondage dans le Nord il ne demande
effectivement qu'à aller servir sur sur
place et en proximité je je partage
l'opinion qui a été dite sur les soins
palliatifs mais cel je crois que c'est
vraiment une opinion qui est unanime
sur le développement il y a il y a quand
même des crédits qui sont désormais
prévus sur cela le plan en disant me
paraît me paraît une très bonne chose
sur les la la la la la prévention
précoce on s'est d'abord préoccupé
effectivement des enfants de moins de 6
ans il faudra effectivement voir quel
est si si on arrive à suivre ne
serait-ce qu'en terme de personnel et
puis voir comment les choses peuvent se
compléter sur les enfants de 7 à 12 ans
je signale d'ailleurs que là aussi les
départements parce que il faut bien que
les départements soi aussi à être très
présent dans ses politiques les
départements son extrêmement intéressés
par la détection précoce du handicap
chez l'enfant parce que parmi ces
enfants il y a énormément d'enfants de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance vous savez
les enfants de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance c'est un un des plus grands
échecs de notre de de de notre
République puisque vous envoyez beaucoup
dans à la sortie de l' sociale à
l'enfance dans dans en cent domicile
fixe dans la rue et vous en retrouvez
beaucoup effectivement dans les prisons
je signale d'ailleurs lorsqu'on parlait
effectivement du problème du handicap et
des moyens insisant sur le handicap qui
a aussi un dossier que moi j'ai bien
connu quand j'étais sénateur qui est le
dossier effectivement du nombre de
malades mentaux qui se trouvent dans les
prison française alors qu'ils n'ont rien
à y faire et qu' devrait au contraire
être pris en charge médicalement ce ce
qui n'est pas le cas je te laisse
enchaîner
euh vu de ma fenêtre vous avez interrogé
madame la sénatrice
les le modèle des services d'aide à
domicile c'est vrai que euh
la difficulté à voir se rétablir la
situation du secteur dans un contexte où
des financements importants
nouveaux sont ont été alloués sur la
période récente je le redis avec la mise
en place du tarif planancher avec le
développement progressif de la dotation
complémentaire interroge
euh
il nous il y a plusieurs actions qui
sont
conduites de manière parallèle
les financeurs évidemment travaillent et
vont travailler dans le cadre des
commissions départementales à j'allais
dire ouvrir le capot hein des modèles
économique des structures accompagnées
pour qu'au-delà de l'aide très
ponctuelle ce soit bien des démarches de
rétablissement de l'équilibre qui soi
mise en œuvre c'est important d'autre
part je veux souligner que la la caisse
s'intéresse par exemple est en train de
terminer une
étude très très lourde elle aura duré 3
ans sur des modèles d'organisation
burzor donc en équipe intégrée qui
revoit complètement l'organisation du
fonctionnement de l'aide à domicile en
très grande proximité pour organiser
vraiment l'accompagnement au plus près
et éviter ces organisations de service
où les professionnels passent plus de
temps sur les route qu'auprès des
personnes c'est vraiment du point de vue
de la caisse en allant vers des
organisations en proximité où le
professionnel passe du temps auprès de
la personne ce qui est ce qui correspond
à ses aspirations qu'on ira qu'on
arrivera à trouver un modèle économique
plus satisfaisant euh euh pour le
collectif ça n'empêche pas de
s'interroger en même temps sur le
soutien la mobilité de ses
professionnels dans un contexte où la
branche vient pour la première fois de
procéder au chiffrage carbone de son
empreinte euh
8 méatonnes c'est presque l'équivalent
de la filière ciment béton en France
parmi les trois principaux postes
énergie euh euh alimentation il y a
évidemment la question de la mobilité et
donc le sujet sera à la fois
d'accompagner l'accès à la mobilité mais
à des mobilités plus respectueuses de
l'environnement et c'est
vraisemblablement des proposition qui
pouront être fait dans le cadre de
scénario de décarbonation que nous avons
à construire l'an prochain sur la
capacité de soutien à l'ingénierie à la
fois des opérateurs des communes on a
bien en tête évidemment la démarche du
collectif des mers breton je veux
souligner deux fonds l'un mis en place
l'autre qui va se mettre en place
justement en appuie à la transformation
et à la modernisation d'une part vous le
savez dans le cadre du Segur 100liard 5
dédié à la rénovation la modernisation
des épad mais aussi des résidences
autonomiques en lien avec laacnav ces
fonds s'accompagnent d'une capacité
accru à soutenir financer de
l'ingénierie et nous avons mis en place
avec la naap une mission nationale
d'appuis aux investissement qui peut
intervenir en proximité des opérateurs
pour les projets les plus complexes donc
oui certains opérateurs ont du mal à
disposer des moyens nécessaires à
conduire à ces opérations de rénovation
qui sont capitales nous nous dotons des
moyens de les accompagner en proximité
avec cette mission d'appui
complémentaire des crédits et puis dans
le champ du handicap c'est aussi une
annonce forte de la CNH la mise en place
d'un fond d'appui à la transformation de
500 millions d'euros qui a vocation à
l'image de ce qu'on a pu faire sur le
chandelage à être en capacité de
soutenir j'allais dire d'investissement
dur chaque fois qu'il est nécessaire
mais aussi de l'appui aux organisations
pour qu'ils
évoluent voilà merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup on va passer aux questions
suivantes voilà donc je demande à
Olivier merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Madame la
Directrice évidemment on est sur un
sujet brûlant alors tout le monde a
beaucoup de questions et que c'est sûr
que 1 heure c'est pas c'est pas beaucoup
mais c'est la logique du du temps
juste deux questions donc une première
qui concerne les écarts territoriaux des
des prestations est-ce que ces écarts se
réduisent alors moi je vous avoue que je
suis partagé parce qu'il y a le principe
d'autonomie des départements et de
décentralisation mais est-ce que c'est
tenable à partir du moment où on a cette
logique de branche et on aura demain la
la loi j'espère grand âge hein c'est
c'est la situation paradoxale dans
laquelle on est c'est pas étonnant que
ça craque de partout on a une branche
mais on n' pas la loi grandâge et puis
deuxème question c'est ça concerne le
futur et et et la vision
quelles évolutions voyez-vous pour la
CNSA si vous pensez ou si vous souhaitez
que ça reste le bon outil de gouvernance
de cette branche qui a quand même une
caractéristique c'est de ne pas être
géré de manière paritaire comme une
autre branche je vous remercie merci
beaucoup al Milon oui merci merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Madame la Directrice monsieur
le Président d'abord merci pour la
présentation de ce rapport avec toujours
le même enthousiasme que je vous
connaissais du temps vous étiez
sénateur on vit une période où il y a
une inflation extrêmement importante et
où nos nos concitoyens vivent cette
inflation avec beaucoup de malheur et on
vu une période avec une augmentation
modérée du PIB entre 2022 et 2023 et
vous nous avez annoncé une augmentation
importante du budget de la branche
autonomie et c'est tant mieux mais cette
augmentation importante vient d'une part
importante de la CFG qui par ailleurs
finance une autre branche qui est la
branche maladie est-ce que cette
augmentation de la CSG pour cette
branche là se fait au dépit d'unere
autre branche merci Marie-Pierre
Richet merci monsieur le Président moi
je vais revenir euh je suis là je je
vais revenir euh sur les questions des
questions qui ont déjà été posées mais
pour moi c'est important aussi ça parce
que je voudrais saluer bien entendu le
fond euh dont vous avez parlé mais aussi
vous dire que par exemple pour la région
Centre valde Loire ça représente 800000
€ euh pour les seuls Sades sachant que
le département du Cher pour le le
déficit de nos associations dépasse les
4 millions d'euros à ce jour et que le
département a a a soutenu deux
associations qui sont aujourd'hui en
redressement judiciaire alors moi je va
bien entendre he on peut s'en satisfaire
mais aujourd'hui on est comment vous
avez parlé de virage moi je je dirais
qu'on est dans une sortie de route qui
est quand même très importante et qu'on
se demande comment on va pouvoir
reprendre la route parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est le domiciliaire qui est en
faillite et ça veut dire au-delà du
domiciliaire et des professionnels qui
galèrent si vous me permettez
l'expression et bien ce sont les
bénéficiaires et vous avez évoqué le
bilan carbone alors je vais pas sourire
du bilan carbone mais dans le
département du Cher qui a une très
grande densité avec une population
vieillissante on baissera pas beaucoup
le bilan carbone parce que les les
sociétés ou les associations ne veulent
pas aller au plus loin de de nos
territoires quand il y a simplement deux
trois personnes donc moi ce que je
souhaiterais faire remonter c'est que
bah les fonds c'est bien c'est la la
branche la branche est abondée mais mais
c d'aujourd'hui des dép appartement
comme le Cher qui ne peuvent pas du tout
assurer le le le financement la le
déficit de toutes ces associations et
puis pour aussi rappeler enfin je je
sais que vous le savez mais que souvent
ce qui est pris en compte pour les
associations c'est le temps qu'elle
passe à domicile et pas les fonction
entre guillemets support RH et tout qui
sont qui engendrent aussi ce déficit
donc est-ce que la question s'est posée
merci merci Corine Ferré
oui merci euh il y a déjà eu un certain
nombre de questions posées pour autant
je souhaiterais insister sur quelques
points tout d'abord cette branche est
présentée en excédent certes mais euh
cela ne doit pas masquer le besoin de
financement très important pour prendre
soin des personnes âgées dépendantes
qu'on peut estimer à peu près à 9
milliards annuels 9 milliards d'euros
annuels donc on est euh loin de de ce
dont nous avons besoin nous aurions
besoin les enjeux nouveaux sont majeurs
la refonte en particulier de la prise en
charge de la perte d'autonomie des
personnes âgées ça a été évoqué mais il
faut des moyens il faut des moyens qui
sont aujourd'hui insuffisants tant en ce
qui concerne les personnels qui
interviennent ou les nouveaux postes qui
peuvent être créés vous l'avez évoqué
vous-même monsieur le Président le le
nombre c'est pas après-demain c'est
demain ce nombre très très important de
de postes à créer l'obligation de
formation aussi de toutes ces personnes
qui sont majoritairement des femmes
aussi ne l'oublions pas donc un effort a
été fait effectivement dans le cadre du
segure pour une revalorisation des
salaires ce qui peut expliquer aussi
cette augmentation des dépenses mais ça
suffit pas vous le sait très bien donc
il faudra aller au-delà il faudra aussi
et je rejoins la Millon sur sa question
parce qu'il y a pas de réell nouvelles
ressources mais il y a une fraction de
recettes de CSG qui ont été attribué à
cette branche alors qu de csgelle est
pas
extensible à à volo qu des autres
branches qui pouvaient bénéficier entre
guillemets de cette contribution
vraiment je je m'associe complètement à
cette question je je voudrais insister
aussi çael a été dit mais dans le
Calvados nous le vivons aussi
particulièrement autant par les
établissements que par les structures
associatives notamment qui accompagnent
les personnes âgées à domicile c'est 100
millions d'euros qui ont été attribués
enfin je veux pas être indécente 100
millions c'est une grosse somme mais
ramener au budget de ces structures voir
ramener au budget complet de cette br
branche c'est rien du tout totalement
insuffisant et on est jeose le dire
simplement dans de la communication tout
à fait ponctuelle et qui n'apportera pas
de solution duraable pour toutes ces
structures que comme la rapporteur l'a
rappelé qui sont en grande difficulté
déficit aussi de la médicalisation des
épades là aussi par manque de personnel
donc c'est une question là pour le coup
que je voudrais formuler qu'est-ce qui
est prévu par rapport à cela et enfin
juste terminer euh par rapport au
handicapé spécifiquement l'article 38
qui propose un accompagnement euh pour
les plus jeunes enfants qui souffrent de
trouble du neurodéveloppement je
voudrais souligner si vous l'avez fait
je vous invite à lire le rapport que
nous avons commis avec mes collègues
Justine guidez et Laurent burgera sur ce
sujet qui formulé un certain nombre de
préconisations très beau rapport
Jean-Marie vanberg merci monsieur
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur Monsieur le Président Madame
la Directrice pardon monsieur le
Président
euh rapidement moi je dis vraiment je je
tire le signal d'alarme il y a urgence
certes la trajectoire financière n'est
pas mauvaise par rapport au rapport
Libau et les demandes répété enfin les
rapports répétés qui a pu y avoir on est
dans la bonne trajectoire mais comment
vous allez mobiliser ces
milliards c'est urgent il y a dépôt de
bilan moi j'ai nombre
d'épad pratiquement la moitié pour pas
dire toutes les épades du tous les
épades du département du pad Cadé sont
en dépôt de bilan l'aide à domicile il y
a un collectif qui s'est créé ils sont
en dépôt de bilan ils ont les les les
tarifs c'est plus 23 26 ou 27 c'est
31 soyons sérieux donc qu'est-ce que
vous comptez faire c'est pas avec les
100 milliards qu'on règle le problème là
dans l'urgence moi j'attends une réponse
très claire de la part de la CNSA très
clair je pense que d'ailleurs il y a
aussi un crédit c'est ce que me
rappelait d'ailleurs l'ancienne ministre
de la Santé n dit il y a un crédit
ingénierie et travaux qui était prévu
pour les épades qui est pas suffisamment
sollicité il y a un milliard et demi
pour en faire des des lieux ressources
il y a un fond qualité il est très peu
sollicité aussi et et et les épat n'ont
pas connaissance de ça ou les les
associations non plus donc voilà pour
moi je vous je tire le signal d'
vraiment c'est maintenant qu'il faut
agir merci pour terminer Florence
laarade merci monsieur le Président
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Directrice je voulais revenir sur le
fonctionnement des cams apparemment vous
avez des solutions moi pour avoir été
pédiatre et avoir adressé des enfants au
cams je j'ai constaté comme comme la le
dysfonctionnement entre le libéral et
l'Hospitalier était un frein à la prise
en charge des enfants il fallait
vraiment que ça soit les familles qui
demandent elles-même la prise en charge
et le tout le travail fait en libéral en
particulier par l'Association française
de pédiatrie ambulatoire euh est très
mal pris en compte alors que c'est
relativement économique
euh c'est un dépistage et finalement le
la coura de transmission ne fonctionne
pas alors peut-être que ça c'est
amélioré depuis que j'ai arrêté mon
exercice mais je voulais attirer votre
votre attention là-dessus deuxièmement
il y
a pour les pour les EPAD
un un espoir considérable sur le le
nouveau traitements qui vont arriver sur
l'Alzheimer avec la l'économie que ça
pourrait engendrer pour le pour pour
pour toutes ces ces maisons de retraite
est-ce que vous êtes penché sur le sujet
ou est-ce que c'est complètement hors
sujet la question que je pose voilà
merci très bien merci beaucoup on va
vous demander une réponse vous savez que
le sujet financier est quand même le
sujet qui revient quand même globalement
donc si vous pouvez plutôt focaliser
principalement et moi j'ai entendu la
proposition du président de dire sur les
réponses qui enfin les questions qui
n'aurait pas de réponse un une petite
note serait bienvenue pour pouvoir
alimenter et donc éviter les
frustrations sur les les réponses
manquantes mais le sujet principal bien
entendu c'est quand même le sujet du
financement bien bien quelques éléments
de de de réponse sur sur la disparité
qui est quand même là aussi un point
point important la disparité des
politiques en fonction des territoires
je pense que il y a des progrès qui
s'accomplissent il s'accomplissent
notamment avec la la la la
multiplication des des des des systèmes
d'information qui sont gérés par la CNSA
le SIAP le si mtph qui ne permettent
plus aujourd'hui d'avoir des politiques
totalement erratiques et puis rassurer
peut-être effectivement les tenants et
nous sommes tous de l'autonomie des
collectivités territoriales en disant
que le la la l'uniformité n'est pas
réclamée on demande pas que ça se passe
de la même manière en lozer et à la
ville de Paris on demande simplement que
l'attention qui est portée et que les
moyens qui sont donnés soient des moyens
comparables on en est très très très
loin aujourd'hui mais il y a ça va dans
le bon sens et notamment avec la
multiplication de de de de ces systèmes
d'information qui sont d'ailleurs
souhaités par la plupart des
départements sur le le le le le le
le l'excédent qui a été évoqué il y a un
excédent important est-ce que cet
excédent il a vocation réellement à
attendre 2000 2027 pour être absorbé je
ne crois pas une proposition avait été
faite par le le Conseil qui consistait à
dire que cet excédent devait permettre
de de de d'abonder de 500 millions
d'euros chaque année les les les crédits
d'investissement sur les épades die sait
s'il y en a besoin également de de éepad
et au sens très large c'està-dire il y a
effectivement des des des des des des
des épades qui sont transformés en
résidence euh services senior de la même
manière ils auront besoin effectivement
de crédit tout à fait significatifs pour
pour pouvoir être des des des lieux
agréables de vie pour pour les personnes
âgées sur les camps sur les camps je
crois que c'est l'opportunité puisque
désormais les moyens financiers sont des
moyens plus importants de faire en sorte
que le l'alliance entre les personnels
effectivement public et les personnels
libéraux puissent se faire d'une manière
qui soit une manière peut-être plus
dynamique qu'elle ne l'a été pour le
moment moi j'ai pas eu cette C cette
critique mais je j'ai bien j'ai bien
bien compris votre intervention et c'est
un point sur lequel je me permettrais
également euh d'attirer la d'attirer
l'attention
euh Jean-Marie
euh se connait depuis longtemps tout à
fait euh euh attire l'attention sur sur
sur le le le le nerf de la guerre et le
fond le fond du problème euh la ce
pourquoi ce PLFSS n'a pas eu
effectivement une très large approbation
au niveau de euh de de la du conseil de
la CNSA euh parce que nous ne sommes pas
dans dans une situation de gestion au
fil de au fil de l'eau nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans une situation en ce qui
concerne les personnes âgées qui est une
situation de crise nous sommes face à un
défi démographique que nous n'avons
jamais connu euh je crois qu'on ne peut
le comparer qu'au défi climatique une
différence prè c'est que défi climatique
il dépend pas seulement de nous alors
que le défi démocraphique si on est bon
on arrivera à s'en sortir si on est pas
bon effectivement on on éa les
conséquences les conséquences
dommageables ce défi démographique c'est
à toute la génération du baby boom qui a
aura euh 85 ans en 2030 si vous voulez
pour les les premières générations du du
bb et il va de soit que les problèmes de
dépendance deviendront d'autant plus
importants à ce moment-là j'en parle
avec beaucoup de sympathie puisque j'en
fais partie
moi alors il y a un excédent
effectivement qui qui qui qui est appelé
à être consommé un peu à jusqu'à 2027
rassure-toi Jean-Marie çaira pas jusque
là c'estàd que il va de soit que la
proposition qui a été faite de
de d'investir de consacrer ses crédit à
l'investissement est une proposition
parmi d'autres il y aura peut-être
effectivement préalablement la nécessité
de maintenir IR en vie les structures
effectivement d'aide à domicile et les
épades qui a qui en souffent
considérablement ça veut pas dire qu'il
faudra effectivement sauver n'importe
quelle structure et sauver n'importe
quelle épad il y a des épades qui a
doivent changer de statut si vous voulez
il y a des épades effectivement
où le taux de de fréquentation a baissé
de manière importante et ne risque pas
effectivement de se reconstituer donc
ces épades transformonsles mais cette
transformation elle exigera également
des frais transformonsles en logement
intermédiaire et immédiatement vous
aurez effectivement beaucoup plus de
personnes qui souhaiteront peut-être
plus que vraisemblablement les rejoindre
mais le le le petit matelas de
l'excédent c'est à urgence suprême
éviter effectivement la disparition des
structures notamment d'aide à domicile
alors que on commence à donner quelques
attractivité supplémentaire à ce métier
moi je je connais bien des départements
qui par exemple mettent des flottes de
véhicules à la disposition effectivement
des a missile euh des des flottes de
véhicules qu'elles peuvent utiliser non
seulement pour aller voir le le le le
leurs patients si je peux m'exprimer
ainsi mais aussi pour conduire leurs
enfants à l'école mais aussi pour pour
faire leurs courses et et l'idée c'est
de dire avec le le le le les heures de
convivialité les heures de de de de lien
et bien pour les personnes qui en seront
capables le véhicule peut aussi
permettre à l'aide à domicile d'emmener
la personne sur le marché d'emmener la
personne
sur au cimetière ou ailleurs je
préférrais que ce soit ailleurs qu'au
cimetière mais beaucoup de personnes
âgées qui souhaitent aussi effectivement
avoir ce ce ce ce ce passage qui qui
leur fait du bien ce ce sont c'est aussi
toute la bonne volonté des départements
qu'il faut se poser et la bonne volonté
des départements elle dépend aussi d'une
chose oui mais ce qui est variable aussi
et surtout c'est les moyens financiers
des départements vous savez moi moi j'ai
j'ai mis en place lorsque j'étais
président de la commission des finances
de la DF j'ai mis en place la
mutualisation des DMTO entre les
départements qui a eu des conséquences
extrêmement favorables j'ai pas été
contrarié par la gauche ou par la droite
j'ai j'ai j'ai eu face à moi un conflit
entre les riches et les pauvres si je
peux m'exprimer ainsi mais aujourd'hui
plus personne ne remettrait en cause
cette mutualisation des DMTO seulement
pas de chance la mutualisation des DMTO
elle vit surtout sur les augmentations
de DMTO année après année nous sommes en
période de crise des DMTO donc
aujourd'hui ceux qui bénéficiaient
effectivement de cette solidarité
horizontale n'en bénéficieront raison de
plus pour que la solidarité verticale
soit effectivement pensée à nouveau le
le le gouvernement est d'accord la cadsa
est
d'accord je je je connais bien l'ADF
c'est extrêmement difficile pour un
président d'ADF de dire qu'il est
d'accord pour la refonte globale des
crédits de de la CNSA au département
parce qu'il sait très bien que ceux qui
sont contents de la situation
d'aujourd'hui s'y opposeront et que à
NSA c'est un département une voie mais
aujourd'hui le temps n'est plus à à à
ces ces ces précautions il est
fondamental de revoir les aides de de
l'État au département de revoir cette
péréquation verticale et notamment dans
la péréquation verticale de prendre en
compte les richesses relatives alors je
sais bien que des collègues avec qui je
je me suis toujours bien entendu me
disent mais non on peut plus aujourd'hui
parler de potentiel financier potentiel
fiscal puisque de toute façon on a plus
de de pouvoir fiscal et je leur répond
ça n'empêche que si on prend les revenus
des habitants le niveau de revenu des
habitants est extrêmement disparate d'un
département à un autre et c'est aussi un
critère qui me paraît un critère
important pour assurer le le véritable
principe d'égalité qui consiste pas à
traiter tout le monde de la même manière
mais qui consiste à traiter de la même
manière ceux qui se trouvent dans des
situations identiques et donc
différemment ceux qui se trouvent dans
des situations différent bien
gé une réponse à monsieur le sénateur
mon sur le la recette complémentaire de
CSG et pour vous assurer sur le fait
qu'elle qu'elle ne manquera pas à
d'autres branches dans la mesure où vous
le savez puisque le les textes qui ont
créé la branche étaient des textes
commun à l'organisation de la dette
sociale c une loi organique sur le
financement de la dette sociale et la
création de la branche autonomie et donc
ce ce ce 015 points de CG supplémentaire
affecté et fléché vers la branche
autonomie pour l'année 2024 et les
suivantes provient de financement
antérieur alloué à la cadè pour
l'extinction de la j'allais dire la
vieille dette la dette d'avant covid au
moment du covid la dette sociale a
progressé des financements
complémentaires ont été fléchés vers
l'organisme chargé de de financer cette
dette sociale mais à compté
2024 un un premier volume de dette était
sera mis en extinction et donc c'est
bien les financements correspondants à C
cette ancienne dett qui sont rendu
disponibles et qui peuvent être alloués
à la branche autonomie pour soutenir un
effort une capacité accrue de faire face
au besoins associés au vieillissement je
le redis donc c'est pas il y a pas de de
tuyau entre les entre les entre les
branches et entre les les caisses
nationales et puis pardon un un un mot
pour redire que derrière les enjeux de
financement ce sont en réalité des
enjeux d'organisation et de soutien aux
professionnels qui accompagnent les
personnes âgées et personnes handicapées
au quotidien que nous évoquons puisque
je le redis les financements de la
branche autonomie qu'il s'agisse aussi
bien de se allouer directement par les
ARS aux établissements au servicees ou
ceux qui via les conseils départementaux
permettent de solvabiliser avec la
paille la PCH de l' à domicile notre
trésor notre richesse ce sont les
professionnels et c'est bien eux dont
les financements sont pour partie
apportés par cette
branche il il importe de permettre aux
structures de les rémunérer de les
rémunérer mieux j'ai évoqué les 4
milliards d'euros depuis la création de
la branche alloué à ses revalorisations
et à la déclinaison des 183 € net
mensuel apporté aux professionnels ou la
revalorisation de la BAC qui est
l'équivalent je veux je veux dire que
cette attractivité financière elle est
majeure elle doit être soutenue qu'il
faut aussi que nous consacrions toutes
nos forces à aider les structures à
réfléchir à leur organisation à soutenir
des efforts de formation qui sont
indispensables pour apporter la la
qualité de service
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je
j'invite tous ceux d'entre vous qui sont
désireux de prendre un temps plus long
de réflexion sur l'attractivité des
métiers et les conditions d'exercice de
ces des professionnels à nous rejoindre
en distantiel au 7e rencontre Recherche
et Innovation que nous organisons très
prochainement début novembre précisément
sur la thématique des professionnel qui
interviennent auprès des personnes âgées
en situation de handicap merci ce sera
le mot de fin donc on attend président
quelques réponse complémentaire on a
bien vu les enjeux concernant l'aspect
financement voilà un grand merci et puis
désolé pour cette fin d'audition un peu
rythmée mais nous avons un programme
législatif qui est extrrament chargé
merci beaucou beaucoup et puis j'appelle
Corine